[Musik]
hey lieben wir machen heute leckerlis
ecken nussecken gehören für mich zum
winter immer dazu wobei ich finde warum
macht man im sommer verstehst du das
obwohl ich doch so lecker sind also ich
bin dafür
ja meinte ich bin dafür dass man das
ganze jahr über machen sollte und ich
zeige euch hier wie sie euch total
saftig gelingt nussecken besteht immer
erst mal aus einem mit tag den wir
zuallererst zubereiten und dafür habe
ich hier vier zutaten einmal ganz
klassisches weizenmehl dann habe ich
hier butter die ist auf zimmertemperatur
eier auch gern auf zimmertemperatur und
zucker mit werden alle zutaten
miteinander vermengen
[Musik]
ihr werdet dann relativ schnell
feststellt also nach zwei bis drei
minuten ich persönlich mag das auf der
arbeitsfläche ganz gerne dass der
mürbeteig fest wird also der klebt nur
noch so ein bisschen aber es ist halt
ein festtag der noch weich ist den dem
wir jetzt auf ein mit backpapier
ausgelegtes backblech ich werde euch die
maße auch noch verraten
das sehe ich aber gleich erst nachdem
ich beim backen drum herum gelegt habe
[Musik]
so meine lieben ein backblech hat die
maße 27 x 34 cm
das ist nur so eine ungefähre richtlinie
für euch zu hause und ich habe den teig
jetzt hier ausgebreitet und für mich hat
es wirklich das perfekte konstrukt
zusammen mit meinem mann im bett weil es
eben ebenmäßig ist und nicht diese
wirkung hat und gerade bei so flachen
becken möchte man ja dass es ebenmäßig
bräunt und wir müssen jetzt noch ganz
ganz dringend uns eine gabel schnappen
und in den markt jetzt noch löcher rein
hauen damit der mütter beim backen eben
unten bleibt
jetzt kommt der möglich bis zur
weiterverarbeitung in den kühlschrank
ich denke mal so circa 20 maximal 30
minuten
wir möchten nämlich dass der weg bevor
wir gehen mit mit den weiteren belegen
bestreichen richtig schön fest geht und
eben nicht mehr diese weiche konsistenz
hat ich werde jetzt hier und die bügel
einziehen damit auch mein blech in
meinem kühlschrank bug und breitem schon
mal die nächsten schritte vor für euch
für den nuss belag benötigen wir
natürlich müsse dazu erkläre ich euch
gleich noch ganz kurz was dann habe ich
hier bei miele extrakt und zucker für
die süße etwas leitungswasser und butter
und aprikosenmarmelade die brauchen wir
aber erst später ich gebe es zuallererst
die butter zusammen mit dem wasser in
meinem kopf und lasse das erhitzen
[Musik]
vanille extrakt und zucker sind auch
schon im tauglicher witz den herd auch
schon wieder ausgeschaltet
das kannst du musst ja wirklich nur kurz
schmelzen miteinander verbinden und dann
war's das und als nächstes gehe ich die
nüsse dazu jetzt ist richtig dass sie
einen teil gehackte nüsse und den
anderen teil gemahlene nüsse verwendet
statt der gemeinde müsse könnt ihr auch
kokosflocken das finde ich auch richtig
lecker und ich nehme einfach immer das
was der schrank gerade bietet also in
meinem fall sind es heute gehackte
haselnüsse und gemeinde mandeln
[Musik]
die nuss masse ist fertig also die
lassen wir jetzt nur ganz kurz an die
seite die muss jetzt auch nicht
sonderlich auskühlen oder so und jetzt
hier rüber zu mario ist dafür schwenker
ja ich will jetzt hier grünen beim einem
bachbett habe ich gerade eben aus dem
kühlschrank geholt und da wird jetzt auf
die oberfläche des mit
aprikosenmarmelade verstrichen ich weiß
dass jetzt die frage kommen wird kann
ich auch eine andere marmelade verwenden
zum beispiel erdbeer himbeer das geht
eigentlich prinzipiell aber ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen dass es mit
aprikosenmarmelade einfach am besten
ja das schmeckt auch in verbindung mit
dem müssen und dem bereich
nach der aprikosen masse ganz einfach
die nutzschicht obendrüber verteilen und
den ofen hab ich auch schon vor geheilt
kann ich euch ja schon mal verraten bei
170 grad ober und unterhitze wird das
ganze gebacken für eine halbe stunde
[Musik]
jetzt ist die halbe stunde rum und es
gebe ich euch einen tipp schneidet
nussecken noch warm in quadrate bzw
anschließend in dreiecke denn ansonsten
würden sie brechen wenn die sie komplett
vollständig auskühlen das dann erst
schneidet ich mach das mal so dass ich
wurde ja warm sagt ingo 100 punkte soll
ich da jetzt hier noch einen tortenring
r messer damit ich hier auch den bug
rahm entfernen kann und dann nehme ich
mir zu hilfe einmal so ein einteiler
das könnt ihr müsst ihr aber nicht aber
so ist eben alles gleichmäßig groß
[Musik]
nachdem ihr die nussecken dann
durchgeschnitten habt einfach
vollständig auskühlen lassen
denn in der zeit werden sie richtig
schön fest also hart aber nicht dieses
negative hart sondern schön möge und
fest und man kann sie auch anheben und
in schokolade trinken und für mich
gehört schokolade immer dazu ich habe
jetzt hier ganz einfach
kuvertüre also voll mit kuvertüre
genommen eine mikrowelle geschmolzen und
bisschen kokos vertrauen gegeben ein
glänzte schön jetzt nehme ich mir einen
leckeren dann könnt ihr entscheiden
wollte einfach nur die ränder deinen
schokolade trinken oder nimmt ihr gleich
die hälfte
ja wenn ihnen die hälfte funken sich
rein und lassen sie dann auf backpapier
auskühlen ja nur die hälfte ich mag das
nicht noch mal sein was ist also konnte
das ergreifen
das stimmt da kann man besser anfassen
[Musik]
ich musste mir eins erklären wieso sitzt
du immer die lustigen zweimal hat
folgenden grund also ich denke ja in
kuvertüre dann lasse ich die den
überschuss einfach runter laufen dann
denkt man okay der überschuss ist unten
liegt auf dem backpapier ab das können
wir hier mal kurz zeigen und dann kommt
auf dem backpapier nochmal einen
überschuss an kuvertüre hier ist jetzt
nicht so viel aber ich erlebe es dann
nochmal ab damit eben später nach dem
trocknen die kuvertüre schicht eben
nicht je nach außen läuft
[Musik]
jetzt hoffe ich natürlich dass ihr alle
lust bekommen hat muss ecken zu hause
selber zu machen nach diesem rezept wird
hundertprozentig gelegen hatte die kiki
garantie drauf und dann einfach nur noch
genießen zum kaffee oder tee oder gerne
auch verschenken
ich werde ein teil auch verschenken an
ganz mit den familien freuen weil die
halten sich total lange die halten bis
zu drei wochen aber never ever werden
die so lange halten nur die so lecker
sind ja ich glaube ich muss noch eine
zweite ladung machen haben sagen okay
euch jetzt ganze freude am nachmachen
schaut ihr unten in die infobox das
schreibe ich euch alle ganz genauen
mengenangaben hin die immer ich schreibe
euch außerdem alles was ich im video
genutzt habe was ihr bei mir im
onlineshop findet und dann lassen uns
gerne in den kommentaren miteinander
schreiben schreibt mir gern was sie als
nächstes sehen möchtet dann halte ich
mich da auch gerne dran also ihr lieben
bis zum nächsten loch es geht schon
[Musik]